ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
die bundesministerin für verteidigung
christine lambrecht
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
unsere sicherheit in europa nicht nur in
europa aber auch hier steht aktuell vor
großen herausforderungen und das
informelle treffen der
eu-verteidigungsminister rinnen und
verteidigungsminister dass die
französische ratspräsidentschaft gestern
ausgerichtet hat war ein sehr gutes
format um diese herausforderungen zu
beraten und sie können sich vorstellen
ein ganz zentrales thema hat natürlich
auf der tagesordnung gestanden nämlich
russland und die ukraine
ich sage ganz deutlich der russische
aufmarsch an der ukrainischen grenze
verstößt gegen alle regeln des
friedlichen miteinanders
jeder
jeder russische angriff auf die ukraine
wird konsequenzen nach sich ziehen denn
der konflikt bedroht den frieden in
europa und daher müssen wir europäer uns
auch aktiv einbringen und das tun wir
auch im nato-russland-rat der endlich
der endlich wieder nach zwei über zwei
jahren wieder stattgefunden hat in der
osze überall wo gespräche geführt werden
haben wir europäer eine starke stimme
und das ist auch gut und richtig so
es war die woche es war die woche der
gespräche und es werden weitere
gespräche folgen denn klar ist wir
müssen alle alle mittel ausschöpfen um
diesen konflikt zu entschärfen
gleichzeitig haben wir europäer zusammen
mit den amerikanischen freunden aber
auch deutlich gemacht das völkerrecht
muss gewahrt werden die staatliche
souveränität unserer östlichen nachbarn
ist unantastbar und russland hat kein
vetorecht wenn es um bündnisfragen geht
und kann uns hier auch nicht erpressen
und diese roten linien die müssen klar
sein in all den gesprächen die jetzt
anstehen und niemand niemand hat
erwartet dass diese gespräche mit der
russischen seite einfach werden oder
dass es da ein zwei gespräche dass der
ein zwei gespräche ausreichend sind und
der konflikt ist entschärft nein diese
woche hat gezeigt wie schwer es wird
aber zwischen diesen roten dingen die
ich geschrieben habe und einer
militärischen auseinandersetzung da ist
viel spielraum da zwischen dem bier
intensiv ausschöpfen müssen und das
müssen wir uns zur verantwortung zur
herausforderung auch machen meine damen
hatte die russische aggression
verdeutlicht einmal mehr wir müssen in
europa und wir müssen mit zwischen
europa und der nato eng ganz eng
beieinander steht und in der kommenden
woche treffe ich mich hier in berlin mit
dem nato-generalsekretär jens
stoltenberg und natürlich werden wir uns
auch intensiv über die russische
aggression beraten meine damen und
herren ganz bewusst ganz bewusst bin ich
für meinen ersten truppenbesuch im
ausland angereist zu unserem kontingent
der nato ich war beeindruckt von der
hohen einsatzbereitschaft unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten vor ort und ich
habe mich auch bei ihm bedankt denn jede
und jeder von ihnen steht für eine
wirksame abschreckung dort vor ort und
sie alle machen damit eines sehr
deutlich die sicherheit unserer
verbündeten ist unsere sicherheit auch
und gerade in mittel und osteuropa
die bedrohung durch russland ist das
eine vor uns liegt aber eine ganze reihe
von globaler sicherheitspolitische
herausforderungen und bei all dem gilt
bei all dem gilt deutschland steht zu
seiner verantwortung für den frieden in
europa und der welt und das beweisen wir
auch immer wieder denken sie nur an
unser engagement im kampf gegen den diaz
und zur stabilisierung des irak über das
mandat wird heute nachmittag hier im
bundestag beraten unsere bundeswehr
leistet hier an der seite unserer
partner und verbündeten einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag und vergangen das
wochenende war ich in jordanien und im
rat und ich habe mit unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten dort gesprochen und mir ein
bild über die umstände vor ort gemacht
ich kann ihnen sagen dieser einsatz der
ist entbehrungsreich ja aber er ist auch
gefährlich noch kurz vor meinem besuch
sind wieder einmal raketen auf der alle
assad rbs eingeschlagen aber unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten haben
schutzmaßnahmen ergriffen und gott sei
dank gott sei dank sind alle wohlauf
meine damen und herren wir schulden ist
unseren frauen und männern dass wir
ihren hohen persönlichen einsatz der
sich da wieder gezeigt hat unser ihren
hohen persönlichen einsatz klug und
besonnen abwägen und daher müssen wir
und daher werden wir auch jeden
auslandseinsatz genau evaluieren
selbstverständlich immer im engen und
ehrlichen austausch mit unseren partnern
und verbündeten aber es geht darum ziele
und instrumente zu prüfen und
gegebenenfalls auch anzupassen was
wollen wir erreichen wie es unser
militärischer beitrag in politische und
zivile maßnahmen eingebettet und auch
haben wir eine exit strategie mir ist
sehr bewusst dass diese evaluierung ein
hochpolitischer vorgang ist ja betrifft
die ganze bundesregierung unsere
bündnisse und unsere rolle als
sicherheitspolitischer partner in der
welt wir dürfen einsätze aber nicht auf
das militärische verengen ein einsatz
ist immer auch eine politische maßnahme
und das ist die wichtigste lehre aus
afghanistan jeder einsatz steht und
fällt politisch und es hat nämlich auch
was mit politischen lage im einsatzland
zu tun und ganz konkret mit der frage
wen unterstützen wir eigentlich wen
bilden wir aus und ist dies mit unseren
zielen und werten dann auch vereinbar
und ich sage es ganz konkret in mali
fordert die internationale gemeinschaft
zu recht eine rückkehr zur demokratie
und wahlen und das nicht erst in fünf
jahren wie von dort angekündigt man muss
schnell neuwahlen ansetzen alles andere
ist inakzeptabel und zudem ist es ein
schwerer fehler dass in mali von
russland unterstützte söldner im einsatz
sind sollten die dafür bekannt sind
menschenrechte zu verletzen zu morgen zu
foltern und andere staaten zu
destabilisieren und für unseren einsatz
vor ort gilt deshalb wenn sich im magen
nichts ändert kann es ein einfaches
weiter so dort nicht geben das muss
allen beteiligten sehr bewusste
meine damen und herren die sicherheit
unserer bürgerinnen und bürger die
verteidigung unseres landes und seiner
verbündeten der einsatz für frieden und
freiheit in europa und der welt im
dienste unserer demokratischen offenen
und vielfältigen gesellschaft das ist
die aufgabe unserer bundeswehr und für
diese große aufgabe da werden und da
müssen wir sie auch entsprechend
ausstatten unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten riskieren ihr leben für unser
gemeinwesen umso mehr müssen sie dann
auch darauf vertrauen können dass wir
sind bestmöglich ausrüsten und daher
teile ich die meinung des bundeskanzlers
unsere ausgaben für die verteidigung
müssen weiter steigen wir brauchen
dieses geld
wir brauchen dieses geld um unsere
truppe mit den wild mit dem nötigen
material auf zu versorgen da geht es von
den ganz kleinen projekten bis zu den
großen multinationalen vorhaben von
bitte an betriebsstoff über ersatzteile
und persönliche bekleidung bis hin zu
einsatzbereiten flugzeugen und schiffen
oder panzern aber es geht auch nicht nur
ums geld wir müssen auch das beste
herausholen aus dem was wir schon haben
hier gab und gibt es immer noch zu viele
missstände hubschrauber die nicht
fliegen gewähre die nicht treffen haben
zu oft zu oft für gesperrt gesorgt daher
werde ich weiß das ist ein ganz dickes
brett das zu bohren ist aber ich werde
das beschaffungswesen gründlich
modernisieren
und diese diese modernisierung sie wird
reichen da geht es um eine flexiblere
haushaltsführung es geht um das
vergaberecht dass wir verändern müssen
es geht um mehr effizienz auch digitale
effizienz mir ist auch klar dass wir uns
die strukturen der beschaffung genau
ansehen müssen und ich weiß es ist eine
große herausforderung aber mein spruch
ist immer wenn es einfach wäre würden es
andere machen meine damen und herren ich
habe unsere truppe nun schon einige mal
besucht zu hause und im einsatz viele
gespräche geführt mit unseren frauen und
männern in uniform und in zivil und ich
kann ihnen sagen wir haben eine hoch
motivierte truppe auf die sich unsere
bürgerinnen und bürger zu recht
verlassen können das zeigt sich immer
dann wenn es darauf ankommt
beispielsweise im vergangenen sommer
weiter fluthilfe und jetzt einmal mehr
in der pandemie seit zwei jahren sind
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten hier im
einsatz gegen das gefährliche virus auch
unserer reservistinnen und reservisten
in impfzentren testzentren und im
pflegeheim sie helfen in den
gesundheitsämtern beim krankentransport
oder bei der internationalen chor ohne
hilfe und sie tun das oft unter sehr
schwierigen bedingungen dann auch sie
werden ähnlich wird die polizei
beleidigt bepöbelt und das belastete und
deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
allen soldatinnen und soldaten dient
dieser pandemie den menschen in unserer
in unserem ganz zur seite stehen sehr
ausdrücklich und von herzen danken aber
ich sage auch sehr deutlich danke zu
sagen alleine reicht nicht wir werden
deshalb auch genau prüfen ob die
anrechnungsregelungen von zulagen sowie
sie für die polizei angedacht sind ob
wir das auch für die soldatinnen und
soldaten umsetzen können ich denke dass
wir ein richtiges ein wichtiges signal
aber auch persönlich handeln die
soldatinnen und soldaten hoch
verantwortlich über 90 prozent haben
sich impfen lassen also deutlich mehr
als die impfquote ansonsten
durchschnittlich hergibt und diesen
verantwortlichen diesen solidarischen
geist unserer truppe den gilt es zu
bewahren und wir müssen hingegen
diejenigen verteidigen die unsere werte
nicht teilen gegen die hetze gegen die
menschenverachtenden verschwörungs
geschichten gegen den
rechtsextremistischen hass und lassen
sie mich hier sehr deutlich sagen es
gilt null toleranz gegenüber jeder form
von extremismus ein wegschauen eine
falsch verstandene
kameradschaft darf es nicht geben und
wir werden extremisten konsequent
verfolgen und schnell sehr schnell aus
der bundeswehr entfernen auch auch durch
eine reform der soldaten rechtlichen
vorschriften die jetzt sehr schnell
kommen wird denn zu einer starken
bundeswehr gehört eines ganz sicher dass
man mit beiden beinen fest auf dem boden
unseres grundgesetzes steht und dass man
die werte lebt für die man kämpft vielen
dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege florian horn
für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin
möchte eins vorweg nehmen
viele stellen die sie genannt haben
teile ich und teilt meine fraktion und
das gilt vor allem für die letzten sätze
und dessen partnern sie zur bekämpfung
des extremismus auch in der truppe
benannt haben da haben sie uns an
unserer seite diese einzelfälle müssen
ganz entschlossen angegangen werden
darauf können sie sich auch auf unsere
unterstützung verlassen
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin im
sommer wollten sie ja noch aus sich aus
der politik zurückziehen und ihren
wohlverdienten ruhestand genießen umso
mehr freue ich mich dass ich ihnen nun
mehr für ihre neue amtszeit allzeit eine
glückliche hand und gottes segen
wünschen kann und das tue ich aus vollem
herzen denn sie sind nun
bundesministerium der verteidigung und
damit die dienstherren eines ganz
besonderen hauses mit ganz besonderen
menschen die nicht nur bereit sind ihren
beruf mit
außergewöhnlichen pflichtbewusstsein
nachzugehen sondern für die sicherheit
deutschlands und seiner bevölkerung
sowie den bündnispartnern besondere
entbehrungen hinzunehmen und dem zweifel
leib und leben zu riskieren
aber niemand kann erwarten dass sie als
politikerin die in ihrer langen karriere
bisher wenig erfahrung in diesem
themenfeld gesammelt hat nach wenigen
tagen bereits jeden dienstgrad aufzählen
kann oder gar alle untiefen der
verteidigungspolitik kennen kann aber
sie sind trotzdem jetzt die ebook die
inhaberin der befehls und kommandogewalt
und das erfordert die tausendprozentige
bereitschaft sich mit voller energie und
einsatz kraft in das für sie neue thema
zu stürzen so wie es ihren beiden
vorgängerinnen auch sehr gut und
manchmal kann ein staat auch ein
bisschen holprig sein zu berichten
mitarbeiter ihres hauses als auch die
medien von einer eher kühlen übernahme
des ressorts auch gab es bis heute weder
am ersten dienstsitz in bonn noch in
ihren hier in berlin eine
mitarbeiterversammlung das ist schon
eher ungewöhnlich aber egal die spielt
keine rolle mehr wenn man dennoch seine
formulierungen klug wählt und die
richtigen ziele beschreibt und da war
dass die rede heute hier schon ein
fortschritt im gegensatz zu einem
anderen fall nämlich ihrem prominenten
interview in der bild am sonntag dort
haben sie frau ministerin unzähligen
soldatinnen und soldaten auf die füße
getreten das zeigt sich nicht nur in
zahlreichen briefen sondern auch in
kopien von eingaben an die
wehrbeauftragte von denen ich kenntnis
habe pro ministerin noch einmal niemand
erwartet von ihnen dass sie bereits
jetzt vollumfänglich
kenntnis über laufbahn gruppen oder die
personalentwicklung haben aber wie
kommen sie dazu bereits jetzt davon zu
sprechen dass frauen ausgebremst werden
oder die männer die top-jobs unter sich
ausmachen wo und wie haben sie die
gläserne decke
identifiziert an die soldatinnen stoßen
sie wollen das in ihrer ersten amtszeit
noch zu einer ersten frau general
außerhalb des sanitätsdienstes kommt
wissen sie dass es hierzu bereits jetzt
schon eine frau oberst geben müsste
damit dies in dieser legislatur
überhaupt möglich ist ich möchte einmal
drei dingen sagen zum begriff job der
soldatenberuf ist kein beruf wieder
andere und deshalb passt der begriff job
schon gar nicht und zweitens da frauen
erst seit dem jahr 2000 den aktiven
militärdienst in der bundeswehr ausüben
können ist es überhaupt nicht möglich
dass frauen bereits heute oberst sind
und deshalb gibt es auch keine außerhalb
des sanitätsdienstes und drittens
regierung und parlament haben in den
letzten jahren alles daran gesetzt dass
es verschiedene förderprogramme für
soldaten in der bundeswehr gibt und dass
eventuelle karriere nachteile
beispielsweise aufgrund von elternzeit
ausgeglichen werden ich möchte deswegen
festhalten es gibt keine gläserne decke
und wer das behauptet der schade der das
wert und irritiert vor allem die frauen
und männer des personalmanagements
außerdem wird damit den soldaten hier
ein ehrenrühriges und
kameradschaftliches verhalten
unterstellt und das weise ich
ausdrücklich zurück
frau
ministerin weder im koalitionsvertrag
noch in der heutigen rede ist eine klare
marschrichtung in der
verteidigungspolitik deutlich gemacht
worden wo es die im haus
koalitionsvertrag beschriebene
bestandsaufnahme das sind einige ihrer
kabinettskollegen deutlich weiter
erscheint die haben sich über den
jahreswechsel intensiv in ihren neuen
aufgaben eingearbeitet und frau
ministerin als fachpolitiker wissen wir
dass die bundeswehr weiter modernisiert
werden muss in allen steckt der general
zorn so wie ihre vorgängerinnen kramp
karrenbauer hatten in den letzten zwölf
monaten gerade auch mit blick auf die
stadt auf den strategischen kompass der
eu
abgeleitet aus der gemeinsamen
bedrohungsanalyse aufgezeigt wo die
lücken zwischen auftrag und
verteidigungshaushalt sind wie wollen
sie damit umgehen die untersuchungen und
anpassungsoptionen liegen alle auf dem
tisch und dann entscheiden sie wie geht
es mit dem haushalt weiter da kann man
sagen ja das ist eine binse er muss
natürlich muss er steigen aber sehr
geehrte damen und herren mit blick auf
den koalitionsvertrag stelle ich fest
statt klare bekenntnisse zu unseren
bündnisverpflichtungen wird das nato
zwei prozent ziel heimlich kassiert und
unter dem deckmantel eines 3 prozent
ziels für internationales handeln wird
in wahrheit die ausgabenkürzungen der
bundeswehr vorbereitet und damit es die
bringenden notwendige und geplante
vollausstattung der truppe gefährdet und
das werden wir ihnen von der
regierungskoalition sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen nicht
durchgehen lassen und frau ministerin
und frau ministerin die cdu csu fraktion
habe sie schon immer ganz besonders für
die sicherheitspolitik und für unsere
bundeswehr eingesetzt und deshalb
erlauben wir uns noch ein paar konkrete
forderungen an sie zu richten leiten sie
die sofort nachfolge beschaffung des
tornados ein die fakten liegen alle auf
dem tisch riskieren sie durch
verzögerung nicht höhere ausgaben
unnötige fähigkeitslücken und den
vertrauensverlust bei unseren parat
halten sie an der nuklearen teilhabe
fest sie ist und bleibt fundamentaler
bestandteil der nato und ist ein
zentraler beitrag deutschlands für die
sicherheit europas
entscheiden sie schnell über den
dringend benötigten schweren
transporthubschrauber sorgen sie dafür
sie haben das beschrieben unter welchen
unter welchen
unter welchen voraussetzungen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten in mali dienst
leisten sorgen sie dafür dass unsere
kräfte in der sahel-zone schnellstens
durch bewaffnete drohnen geschützt
werden und stellen sie sicher dass wir
am ende dieser legislaturperiode
die führungsfähigkeit und
einsatzbereitschaft einer heeres
division nicht nur per powerpoint
sondern real verfügbar haben wir haben
das zuletzt der frühere außenminister
maß international zugesichert und wir
brauchen voll ausgestattete führungs
fähige und aus sich heraus eine
einsatzfähige landstreitkräfte und liebe
kolleginnen kollegen sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin die ernst die
sicherheitspolitische lage ist zeigt die
situation an der ukrainischen grenze und
ich bin dankbar dass sie diese auch
nicht nur erwähnt sondern vollumfänglich
dargestellt haben wir teilen das diese
realitäten zeigen dass im zweifel es
notwendig ist einem zu allen mitteln
entschlossenen herausforderer ebenso
entschlossen entgegentreten zu können
nur das wird ihn erfolgreich aufhalten
und deshalb brauchen wir eine starke
bundeswehr eine starke nato und ein
starkes freies europa das zusammen und
abschließend möchte ich allen unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten sowie den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern der
bundeswehr zu rufen danke für ihren
dienst und gottes segen für ihr
zukünftiges schaffen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
während das bild hier vorbereitet wird
wofür ich mich übrigens herzlich
bedanken dass das
[Applaus]
ich starte ich mir den hinweis dass die
allgemeinverfügung der präsidentin
eindeutig ist die maske kann am redepult
abgenommen werden die amtierenden
präsidentinnen und präsidenten tragen
keine maske und natürlich zur
kurzintervention am mikrofon kann man
zur iss und verständlichkeit die maske
abnehmen
zwischenrufe sind nicht in der
allgemeinverfügung beinhaltet ich bitte
sie darauf zu achten nun hat aber die
kollegin agnieszka broker für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sicherheit
frieden und internationale
zusammenarbeit sind leider keine
selbstverständlichkeiten sie müssen
gelebt erarbeitet und in krisenzeiten
auch immer wieder beschützt werden wenn
autokraten mit
menschenrechtsverletzungen und
militärische aggression oder mit
erpressungs manövern ihre geopolitischen
machtinteressen durchdrücken wollen wie
wir es gerade durch die kreml führung in
der ukraine sehen dann ist das wieder
und unserem interesse noch dürfen wir
uns das bieten das
es bedeutet unsere gesellschaften vor
gezielter spaltung zu schützen unsere
bisherigen bündnisse zu stärken und neue
allianzen zwischen
verantwortungsvolle sicherheitspolitik
in einer hoch vernetzten welt bedeutet
aber auch vor ein kluges zusammenspiel
von diplomatie entwicklungen und
verteidigen wer zum beispiel waffen an
autokraten oder aggressoren genehmigt
stellt geschäftemacherei über die
glaubwürdige botschaft für
internationales recht und trägt am ende
zu instabilität und im schlimmsten fall
zu menschenrechtsverletzungen und
kriegsverbrechen bei deshalb ist eine
strengere und verantwortungsvolle
rüstungsexportpolitik mit einem gesetz
wie wir sie im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben ein aktiver und starker
beitrag zu mehr sicherheit
und gerade weil die zeitfenster für
nukleare abrüstung so selten und so
wertvoll sind wäre es fatal sie
verstreichen zu lassen deshalb auch dass
gerade in schwierigen zeiten und immer
in enger abstimmung und somit
solidarität mit unseren partnern eine
offensive für rüstungskontrolle und auch
den beobachterstatus beim atomwaffen
verbots vertrag und erweitere
abrüstungsinitiativen wie wir sie
miteinander vereinbart haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
gerade weil kohärenz in der
sicherheitspolitik so wichtig ist herr
kollege hahn war ich doch schon sehr
verwundert über ihre rede ich weiß nicht
was sie mit dem wort marschrichtung
meinen wenn ich an die letzten jahre
hier zurückdenke erinnere ich vor allem
mehrere ministerinnen und minister aus
ihrer partei die einfach mal
international vorgeprescht sind ohne
sich mit den anderen ressorts ohne sich
mit dem koalitionspartner abzustimmen
frau ministerin ich möchte mich bei
ihnen herzlich bedanken in diesen
wenigen aber doch sicherheitspolitische
unruhigen wochen haben wir eine andere
kultur der zusammenarbeit erlebt und ich
glaube das ist eine grundvoraussetzung
dafür dass sicherheitspolitik auf
weiteres seien
und dafür braucht es auch nicht dieses
altväterliche mainstreaming was wir hier
gerade von der union gesehen haben
und ja
mit der enthüllt wird noch einiges mehr
anders und ich würde auch sagen besser
in der deutschen sicherheits prüft es
ist doch ein novum dass ein
untersuchungsausschuss nicht von der
opposition eingefordert wird sondern
dass sich die parteien im rahmen der
sondierungsgespräche auf die einrichtung
eines solchen zur aufklärung der
ereignisse rund um den abzug aus
afghanistan verständigt haben das ist
eine andere politische kultur die sich
verantwortung und realität gestellt
nicht um abzurechnen sondern um aus den
fehlern der vergangenheit zu lernen und
sie in der zukunft nicht so wiederholen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nach 16
jahren union im verteidigungsministerium
blicken wir auch zurück auf 16 jahre mit
vielen skandalen viel pr spektakel einer
unrealistischen trendwende nach der
nächsten viele probleme sind einfach
verschleppt und vertagt worden sie haben
sich verschärft und damit muss nun
endlich schluss sein so skizzieren wir
zum beispiel in unserem
koalitionsvertrag mit nur ganz wenigen
worten eine sehr grundlegende umkehr bei
den beschaffungsentscheidungen weg von
einer politik die sich vor allem an den
wahlkreis wünsche von unionsabgeordneten
und den interessen der rüstungsindustrie
orientiert sondern den bedarf der
bundeswehr und den verantwortungsvollen
umgang mit steuergeld in den mittelpunkt
stellt und das ist sowas von überfällig
meine damen und herren wir
wollen aber auch die persönliche und
materielle ausstattung die vereinbarkeit
von familie und dienst die
führungskultur die fürsorge und all das
was auch hier liegen geblieben ist
zusammen angehen im sinne der so so
vielen engagierten menschen bei der
bundeswehr ihren dienst mit einer so
hohen einsatzbereitschaft und
beeindruckenden überzeugungen unter
schwierigen bedingungen leisten
und das ist eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit
und es ist auch nicht nur ausdruck von
dankbarkeit und wertschätzung sondern
auch ganz entscheidend für die frage wer
sich mit welcher motivation für diese
schwierige aufgabe entscheidung denn zu
recht stellt unsere gesellschaft sehr
hohe anforderungen an all diejenigen die
im auftrag unseres staates das
gewaltmonopol ausüben und die zugang zu
militärischer ausbildung und zu waffen
haben es gibt in der bundeswehr nicht
nur eine sehr hohe impfquoten sondern
die soldatinnen und soldaten leisten
schon lange beeindruckendes bei der
bewältigung der pandemie aber die fälle
von radikalen verschwörungs ideologen
beschädigen gerade die tolle arbeit so
vieler menschen aus der bundeswehr und
auch das vertrauen in unsere
sicherheitsbehörden und das sind keine
kleinen einzelfälle wie auch die
enthüllungen rund um
rechtsextremistische fälle der letzten
jahre deutlich zeigen alle verächter
unseres staates in unseren
sicherheitsbehörden sind ein eklatantes
sicherheitsrisiko und frau ministerin
ich bin ihnen dankbar dass sie das in
dieser klarheit heute hier angesprochen
wir müssen mit großer wachsamkeit noch
genauer hinschauen lückenlos aufkläre
auch gerade die verbindung zwischen
rechtsextremismus und antisemitismus
zwischen reis bürgern und verschwörungs
ideologen im blick haben und bei den
erkannten fällen noch viel
entschlossener schneller und härter
handeln auch dazu haben wir uns im
koalitionsvertrag verpflichtet denn wer
unseren staat ablehnt kann und darf
nicht in seinen diensten stehen
meine damen und herren gemeinsam haben
wir uns viel vorgenommen und wir wollen
aus der mitte europas heraus und
gemeinsam mit unseren vielen partnern
mit kooperation mit klarheit und
konsequenz für frieden sicherheit und
menschenrechte eintreten und dabei
deutlich machen eine kollegin gut
erwehren müssen doch eine politik der
stärke vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete rüdiger
lucassen für die fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sie haben
einen gesunden
abgeordneten der täglich seinen kroner
test negativ
nachweist aus dem plenarsaal verwiesen
und verband sie haben sie haben die
macht dazu aber ob das klug ist wird
sich schneller weiß der vor fast 160
jahren ermordete präsident abraham
lincoln sagte
willst du den charakter eines menschen
erkennen so gibt ihm macht sehr geehrte
präsidentschaft laden sie mit mitte
möglichst schnell zu einer
interfraktionellen besprechung ein die
geeignet ist eine lösung zu finden die
diesem haus die würde und den respekt
zurück bereit die es vor den augen der
bürger in unserem land dringend benötigt
ich habe die uhr an das heißt von ihrer
verbleibenden redezeit wird jetzt nichts
weg gehen ich mache sie darauf
aufmerksam dass ihnen nicht das recht
zusteht die amtierende präsidentin in
ihrer amtsführung in der laufenden
sitzung zu kritisieren und ihr handeln
zu bewerten
im wiederholungsfall behalte ich mir den
entsprechenden ordnungsruf und die
vorgesehenen maßnahmen zu für alle die
noch nicht so lange unter uns sind
sollte es und das kann vorkommen auch
berechtigte kritik am handeln von
amtierenden präsidentinnen und
präsidenten geben dann gibt es einen ort
und ein gremium in dem das geklärt wird
das ist der ältestenrat des deutschen
bundestages in dem alle fraktionen
vertreten sind und sollte es zu
fehleinschätzungen gekommen seien oder
anderen dingen dann wurde ich
selbstverständlich auch
öffentlich nachvollziehbar kritisiert
sie haben das wort jetzt zu ihrem
redebeitrag namens der afg front
danke frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren sehr geehrte frau ministerin
lambrecht nehmen sie es einen
klassischen
verteidigungspolitiker wie mir nicht
übel wenn die erwartungen an ihrer
amtsführung nicht sehr groß das hat zwei
gründe zum einen erklärten sie selbst
noch im november 2020 ihren ausstieg aus
der politik stichwort glaubwürdigkeit
zum anderen haben wir den vergangenen
acht jahren viel erfahrung mit
fachfremden
verteidigungsministerin machen können
das wieder voreingenommen sind ist
menschen aber sollte es doch anders als
erwartet kommen und sie schaffen es die
bundeswehr voranzubringen so wie sie es
heute auch schon angedeutet werde ich
meine vor einigen eingenommen haid an
dieser stelle als fehler zu gehen im
übrigen
im übrigen das sei an dieser stelle auch
gesagt haben ihre männlichen
amtsvorgänger ebenfalls er sagt weder
also ein mann als bvg-chef ist ein
garant für solide
verteidigungspolitik und schon gar nicht
war es die cdu die aufgabe
die aufgaben die vor ihnen liegen sind
ms sind im großen und ganzen die
gleichen geblieben wie bei ihren
vorgängerinnen
exemplarisch willich nennen erstens
die großen beschaffungsvorhaben
elementare waffensysteme brauchen
dringend nachfolger tornado schwere
transporthubschrauber ganze
fähigkeitslücken müssen geschlossen
werden taktisches
luftverteidigungssystem bewaffnete
drohnen
zweites die personalgewinnung der
bundeswehr muss zukunftsfähig gemacht
werden in den fachblättern wird seit
wochen über eine weitere verkleinerung
der bundeswehr
gemunkelt das wäre eine fatale
entscheidung für die sicherheit
deutschlands
der ehrliche grund für diese planspiele
ist folgender seit aussetzung der
wehrpflicht vor zehn jahren ist es zu
keinem zeitpunkt gelungen ausreichend
personal für die bundeswehr zu gewinnen
es wäre ein fataler ausweg über eine
reduktion der truppenstärke nachzudenken
das wäre ein offenbarungseid
und drittens und erziehen sie die
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr einer
ernsthaften prüfung tun sie das was alle
bundesregierungen immer sagten und
ziehen sie die lehren aus dem
gescheiterten
afghanistan-einsatz die deutschen
kontingente in mali und im irak tragen
eben nicht zur stabilisierung bei in
mali wird am laufenden band geputscht
und im irak beschließen sich die
volksgruppen mit raketen und mit drin
unsere bundeswehr mit unklaren auftrag
und ohne strategie im besten fall
schaffen es unsere soldaten und sie
haben es verdient selbst gesagt keine
verluste zu erleiden das ist aber zu
wenig frau
ministerin wirklich erfolgreich an die
großbaustellen der bundeswehr gehen zu
können müssten sie aber das tun was seit
1990 keiner regierung gelungen ist sie
müssten eine etage höher gehen und die
da salz frage für die bundeswehr endlich
belastbare beantworten wozu wollen wir
deutsche streitkräfte haben eine ganz
einfache frage mit einer extrem
schwierigen antwort vielleicht hilft die
folgende herangehensweise stellen sie
sich vor
deutschland hätte keine bundeswehr für
welchen zweck würden sie aufstellen um
sie nach mali oder in den irak zu senden
wohl kaum um sie in gesundheitsämtern
oder bei aufräumarbeiten nach einer
naturkatastrophe
einzusetzen sicherlich nicht geben gehen
sie diese liste weiter durch und sie
kommen am ende zwangsläufig bei der
einzige vertretbaren aufgabe für
deutsche streitkräfte an die
daseinsvorsorge für die bundesrepublik
deutschland sicherzustellen so wie es im
grundgesetz steht aber die wirkliche
schwierigkeit besteht darin
zu definieren was die bundeswehr dazu
benötigt um diese frage seriös zu
beantworten braucht man eine ehrliche
bedrohungsanalyse nicht nur für heute
sondern für die nächsten 10 bis 20 jahre
man muss die verlässlichkeit von
bündnissen abschätzen und man muss den
deutschen anspruch und europa und in der
welt definieren wenn dies alles
steht dann fallen auch alle anderen
fragen der verteidigungspolitik leichter
wie viel soldaten brauchen wir die
panzer schiffe drohnen brauchen wir und
welchen ansprüchen müssen unsere
soldaten genügen ich möchte ihnen
deshalb vorschlagen eine
veranstaltungsreihe und der führung des
bmvg zu initiieren als startschuss für
diese wichtige frage wozu brauchen wir
streitkräfte und wenn sie heute erwähnt
haben dass sie das
beschaffungswesen
grundsätzlich und gründlich erneuern
wollen dann empfehle ich ihnen da
anzufangen wo wir alle den abholen punkt
haben beim grundgesetz und sich zu
überlegen ob die trennung von 87 a und b
noch zeitgemäß ist frau ministerin
frau ministerin am tag für mich haben
sie den wichtigsten posten im
bundeskabinett in sie sich
verantwortlich für die daseinsvorsorge
unseres landes käme es bei mal zum
äußersten auch hier im saal aber auch
mit der gesellschaft treten alle gut
daran sich dieses wieder mehr bewusst zu
machen damit die vorbereitung auf das
schlimmste gelingt und dieses in gottes
namen nie eintreten würde ich danke
ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
das wort hat der kollege dr markus
ferber für die fdp
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren wir sind die vortrags koalition
auch im bereich verteidigung
wir packen jetzt das an was die
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
16 jahre lang liegen gelassen haben was
ihnen 16 jahre lang zu heiß war deswegen
japan war nicht ihre
diffamierungsversuche hier gerade von
hier vorne auch völlig deplatziert sie
hatten 16 jahre lang zeigt unsere arbeit
beginnt jetzt und wir machen sie auch
möchte mich hier auch drei fortschritts
dem konzentrieren erstens deutschlands
rolle in der welt wir stehen mit dieser
koalition zu unseren verpflichtungen in
den internationalen organisationen denen
er mitglied sind in den vereinten
nationen in der europäischen union aber
eben auch unter den 30 nato-staaten die
verträge die diese republik dort
unterschrieben hat die werden wir auch
einhalten und zwar gegenüber allen
unseren partnern
das heißt auch unseren partnern in
osteuropa und meine damen und herren es
ist völlig
verständlich wenn man sich
beispielsweise mal die baltischen
staaten anguckt dass sie mit großer
sorge und angst an die russisch
ukrainische grenze gruppen wenn das
regime putin dort über 130.000 mann in
voller ausstattung zusammenzieht 90 die
bayerische geschichte vergegenwärtigt
dann weiß man dass sie sich zu recht
sorgen machen und einen anspruch haben
an die größte volkswirtschaft europas
das einwohnerstärkste land in der mitte
europas ihren bündnispartner dass wir
unsere verpflichtungen in der nato
erfüllen und diese koalition sagt wir
werden diese verpflichtungen auch zu 100
prozent erfüllen
zweitens zweitens ausrüstung wir wollen
dass diese bundeswehr im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ankommt
dazu gehört zuallererst die auch die
persönliche ausrüstung der 185000
soldatinnen und soldaten
das sind häufig einfache dinge das ist
ein helm in dem man kommunikation
integrieren kann das ist eine
schutzweste mit der man sich auch noch
bewegen kann und das sind auch hosen und
stiefel die zeitgemäß sind und mal bei
den einfachen dingen anzufangen und das
muss im einsatz in ausreichender zahl
vorhanden seien beispielsweise auch in
mali bei 40 grad im schatten und das
muss aber auch zu hause im training und
in der übung und dem grund dienst
vorhanden sein daran werden wir jetzt
arbeiten wir müssen die hürden im
beschaffungswesen abschaffen wir müssen
die prozesse schneller machen das ist
die erste aufgabe und dann können wir
uns auch im dritten punkt annehmen und
das sind die großprojekte die
großprojekte die über jahre verschleppt
worden sind der schwere
transporthubschrauber wurde hier schon
erwähnt ich bin aber auch sehr dankbar
dass die ministerin jetzt auch in den
ersten wochen schon auf die
koalitionsfraktionen zu bekommen ist mit
dem bundeskanzler das gespräch gesucht
hat um beispielsweise den museumsreifen
tornado endlich einer nachfolge zu
zuführen damit wir endlich eine variante
haben damit wir hier auch die bundeswehr
im 21 jahrhundert fahren kann und wir
haben im koalitionsvertrag
wir haben den koalitionsvertrag dafür
auch die nötige grundlage gelegt denn im
koalitionsvertrag finden wir drei
prozent für vernetzte sicherheit
außenpolitik entwicklungszusammenarbeit
verteidigung aus einem guss das
ermöglicht uns diese drei prozent des
bruttosozialprodukts ermöglichen es uns
zu investieren den investitionsstau den
sie nach 16 jahren hinterlassen haben
endlich aufzuräumen das packen wir jetzt
an
ich möchte mich zum kurs möchte mich zum
schluss bedanken möchte mich bedanken
zum einen baldigen genossinnen und
genossen sie haben es ermöglicht dass
wir jetzt auch bewaffnete drohnen
beschaffen ich weiß das war für sie kein
leichter weg da war steinig und schwer
aber sie sind ihnen gegangen und dafür
bin ich ihnen dankbar das war überfällig
und das ist wichtig zum schutz unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten im einsatz ich
möchte mich bedanken
möchte mich bedanken auch bei den
freunden folgen von den grünen dank
ihnen können wir jetzt auch die
nachfolge des tornados in dieser
koalition angehen damit auch dafür
sorgen dass deutschland alle seine
verpflichtungen in der nato erfüllt
inklusive der nuklearen teilhabe mit
neuen kampfjets das ist ja wichtig und
dafür möchte ich mich auch bei ihnen
bedanken und
last but not least möchte mir auch bei
den kolleginnen und kollegen der union
bedanken sie haben nämlich etwas sehr
wichtiges vollbracht sie haben die
stühle frei gemacht damit wir ihren
investitionsstau jetzt aufarbeiten
können damit wir ihren scherbenhaufen
jetzt zusammenstehen können dafür
bedanke ich mich und für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
in st
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich grüße
sie herzlich am freitagmittag und als
nächste in dieser debatte erhält das
wort für die linke der kollege ali al
dailami
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich muss sagen es ist schon erstaunlich
und besorgniserregend zugleich wie die
bundesregierung in den letzten wochen in
zentralen fragen der verteidigungs und
außenpolitik aufgetreten ist da
verkündet die verteidigungsminister von
sie wolle putin hallo sie wolle putin
nun ins visier nehmen die aus dem
ministerium wiederum verwebt die frage
von nord stream 2 mit dem ukraine
russland konflikt und plädiert für eine
härtere gangart damit dann der
bundeskanzler um die ecke kommen muss
und beides wieder einzukassieren danach
reihten sie sich verwundert die augen
weil russland und die usa zum glück und
direkt miteinander reden und verlangen
dass man über ihren kopf nichts
entscheiden darf und soll es sagen ihnen
wer so uneinheitlich und widersprüchlich
agiert der braucht sich doch nicht
ernsthaft darüber zu wundern dass er
nicht als erster gesprächspartner in
frage kommt und zum anderen offenbart
das doch nur die macht politischen
realitäten nämlich dass die deutsche
außen- und verteidigungspolitik in den
entscheidenden fragen den geopolitischen
interessen der usa untergeordnet ist und
da muss muss en damit muss endlich
schluss sein meine damen und herren
sie haben auch dem druck der usa
innerhalb der nato nachgegeben und
wollen nun die rüstungsausgaben weiter
steigern um eben das zu verschleiern
bisher jedenfalls haben sie sind sie dem
rat des bisherigen vorsitzenden der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz gefolgt
und haben einfach mal nach dem motto
tricksen täuschen tarnen die ausgaben
für verteidigung entwicklung und
diplomatie einfach mal so zusammengelegt
und heute haben sie zum ersten mal pro
verteidigungsministerium
dankenswerterweise offen zu offen
ausgesprochen dass die aufrüsten wollen
und haben sogar die unterstützung der
afg ich kann ihnen versichern wir werden
weiterhin die einzige fraktion in diesem
hause sein die konsequent für abrüstung
streiten wird meine damen und herren
und frau verteidigungsministerin aus der
presse und eben nicht im dafür
zuständigen
verteidigungsausschuss durften wir
erfahren dass sie sich in einer
unterredung mit dem bundeskanzler darauf
verständigt haben die bewaffnung der
bundeswehr drohnen voranzutreiben wie
das mit dem im koalitionsvertrag
erwähnten erwähnten weltweiten
friedensförderung zusammenpassen soll es
genauso schleierhaft wie die tatsache
dass sie sich eigentlich in der
vergangenheit immer gegen eine solche
form der bewaffnung ausgesprochen haben
und bereits jetzt sind tausende zivile
opfer die folge der bisherigen
völkerrechtswidrigen drohnen morde der
usa und diese zivilen opfer sind
wiederum mit die grundlage für den hass
auf jene die diese waffen einsetzen und
mit das beste rekrutierungs instrument
für terroristische gruppen also völlig
kontraproduktiv
und die anzahl und die anzahl der
zivilen opfer liegt darin begründet dass
der einsatz der drohnen eben nicht so
zielgenau und sicher ist wie immer
wieder behauptet wird aber auch weil die
hemmschwellen beim einsatz solcher
waffen deutlich gesenkt werden und
dieser völker rechtsbruch und die
zivilen opfer während auf und die
satelliten relays stationen im
rheinland-pfälzischen ramstein so nicht
möglich deshalb kommen sie zur besinnung
beenden sie diese völkerrechts bruch
schließen sie die drohnen mord zentrale
in ramstein und lassen sie die finger
weg von den bewaffneten drohnen meine
damen und herren
und zuallerletzt sie begründen immer ja
frau strack zimmermann ist anstrengend
zuzuhören und zu allerletzt sie
begründen immer wieder die aufrüstung
mit dem schutz der soldatinnen und
soldaten im einsatz ich sage ihnen der
beste schutz der soldatinnen und
soldaten ist ist sie erst gar nicht in
irrsinnige und zum scheitern verurteilte
einsatzzahl auslandseinsätze zu
entsenden wie derzeit in mali wo wir für
einen putsch regierung deren
sicherheitskräfte ausbilden und wie
zuvor 20 jahre in afghanistan kehren sie
zum grundgesetz zurück beenden sie die
auslandseinsätze danke für
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege al dailami
und es folgt für die spd-fraktion die
kollege wolfgang hilbig
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich halte es für unerträglich aus den
kreisen der fraktion die linke gegen die
sozialdemokraten im begriff zu hören wir
werden kriegstreiber und discos
rüstungslobbyist das ist eine maß von 15
sagt dass sie sich daran messen dass ich
hier ganz deutlich zurückweisen und es
zerstört jede form der möglichkeit
irgendwo parlamentarisch
zusammenarbeiten zu können
und frau minister und ich möchte mich
ausdrücklich bei ihnen bedanken je
schneller besuch in litauen in jordanien
im irak und der ihre staatssekretäre
mali hat eindrucksvoll unterstrichen
dass ihnen die soldatin soldaten ihr
einsatz und ihre leistung für unser land
dort wohin wir sie in senden sehr am
herzen
ich möchte auch für die einladung an die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
bedanken steht ihnen wahrscheinlich
selber persönlich besser zu baum gefällt
auf sie dafür dann in den irak zu
begleiten hat dies doch deutlich gemacht
dass sie auf eine enge zusammenarbeit
mit dem parlament und in besonders mit
dem verteidigungsausschuss setzen vor
dem hintergrund der bundeswehr als
parlamentsarmee ist das mehr als eine
geste in den vergangenen jahren hätte
ich mit dies auch so gelegentlich mal
von anderen gewünscht
an dieser stelle möchte ich dem kollegen
hahn auf regen
steht in mainz etwas fordert heraus das
ist auch gut so die bilanz die sie von
16 jahren cdu verantwortung für das
ministerium gezogen haben bis mehr als
blamabel
das stimmt
und wenn ich mir das letzte jahr
anschaue wenn wir uns auseinander
gesetzt haben auch in der koalition
politisch dass wir ein jahr lang
schlichtweg ein wahlkampf der cdu csu zu
lasten der bundesliga erleben durften
und mussten ist genau so blamabel
erinnern sie sich deutlich an die
gespräche über den haushalt wo wir davor
gewarnt haben einfach mal alles ohne
realisierung durch zu schieben wohl
wissend dass das politisch und
finanziell gar nicht unterlegt war ist
und sie haben es trotzdem getan für mehr
die ihre ministerin ein gravierender
politischer fehler der zu lasten der
truppe gegangen ist und das finde ich
blamabel hier dann so auch nicht damit
sozusagen
sehr geehrte damen und herren das klar
und unmissverständlich bekenntnis zu dem
bündnisverpflichtungen nato ist von
unseren partner nationen als versprechen
wahr genommen für ihre sicherheit ohne
einschränkungen einzustehen das
versprechen werden wir ein löst so wie
sie ihr versprechen einlösen für unsere
sicherheit einzustehen und diese
notwendige geschlossen hat ist die
voraussetzung dafür dass man auch mit
russland gespräche führen kann und der
nato russland rat hat eindrücklich
bewiesen dass diese geschlossenheit da
ist mehr denn je unter beweis gestellt
die handlungsfähigkeit der nato unsere
partner in der nato erwarten von uns
dass wir dort eine rolle übernehmen
wegen dieses aktiv unterstützen und
treiben das boden und wenn wir über
ausbildung ausrüstung interoperabilität
in karenz der systeme lasten tang und
fähigkeitsentwicklung sprechen und das
sind nur einige stichworte die auch für
die anzustrebende europäische
konsolidierung der rüstungs konnten der
us industrie gelten dann gilt das
genauso gut für die nato dafür um dieses
alles tun zu können brauchen wir hoch
motivierte soldatinnen soldaten die
stolz sind ihren job auch unsere arbeit
tun zu können und auch zivilbeschäftigte
an die wir genauso gut zu denken haben
und deshalb finde ich es gut und sehr
bemerkenswert unterstützt es
ausdrücklich dass sie hier
formulierungen höheren vorschläge höhere
gestern und heute über die ruhestands
fähigkeit von zulagen ich glaube das
sind wichtige maßnahmen um nämlich auch
in der sozialen ausgestaltung des
soldatenberufs und ich sage auch der
zivilen beschäftigten ausdrücklich dazu
über diese maßnahmen die attraktivität
des soldatenberufs und der aktualität
des engagement bei der bundeswehr zu
unterstützen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit machen wir uns ans werk
es gibt viele dinge die zu suchen sind
und sie dulden kann auf vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege hellmich
als nächstes erhält das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion die kollegin kerstin 4
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsidentin sehr geehrte
frau ministerin sehr geehrte damen und
herren wenn wir hier im parlament über
die deutsche verteidigungspolitik und
die bundeswehr reden geht es vorrangig
um die fragen des
verteidigungshaushaltes der
auslandseinsätze oder um grosse
rüstungsvorhaben
jedoch stehen wir unsere parlaments
gegenüber in der pflicht auch die
sozialen rahmenbedingungen der
soldatinnen und soldaten sowie der
zivilen beschäftigten der bundeswehr auf
höchster ebene zu behandeln gerade
verteidigungspolitik habt eine soziale
dimension wie keinesfalls vernachlässigt
werden darf die regierung hat sich im
koalitionsvertrag in dieser dimension
einige ziele gesetzt dazu zählen den
personalkörper demographie festzumachen
die attraktivität des dienstes zu
erhöhen den übergang von soldaten auf
zeit in die freie wirtschaft zu
verbessern das politische
bildungsangebot zeitgemäßer zu gestalten
und auszubauen sowie die betreuung und
fürsorge von soldaten vor während und
nach den einsätzen zu erweitern diese
ziele der regierung sind begrüßenswert
und ich wünsche der regierung und der
verteidigungsministerin frau lambrecht
bei deren umsetzung viel erfolg ich bin
mir sicher dass den kollegen aus der
regierungsparteien jetzt recht wäre wenn
ich meine rede beenden würde aber den
gefallen kann ich ihnen leider nicht tun
denn wer lieber sind von natur aus immer
kritisch und haben auch was zu meckern
seitdem personellen tiefstand des juni
2016 ist der personalbestand der
bundeswehr kontinuierlich angewachsen
liegt aber dennoch unter der
angestrebten personalstärke von 203.000
nichtsdestotrotz gilt es festzuhalten
dass die trendwende personal einen
beachtlichen volk dargestellt darstellt
umso klarer wird es vor dem hintergrund
des megatrends des demografischen
wandels diese nicht aufzuhaltende
entwicklung ist bereits jetzt eine
strategische herausforderung geeignetes
personal zu gewinnen ist unerlässlich
qualifiziertes personal zu halten aber
genauso und somit muss auch die personal
rezession im selben atemzug genannt und
adressiert werden des weiteren ist die
absicht der regierungskoalition den
übergang von soldaten auf zeit in die
freie wirtschaft zu verbessern gut aber
es ist genauso wichtig den binden
arbeitsmarkt der bundeswehr zu stärken
der ausscheidende soldat auf zeit der
mit der arbeitsweise der truppe und der
wehrverwaltung vertraut ist ist auch in
zivil eine bereicherung für die bundes
werden dabei sollte auch nicht vergessen
werden dass im öffentlichen dienst
ebenfalls personalmangel herrscht in den
nächsten zehn jahren wird knapp ein
viertel der im öffentlichen dienst
beschäftigten das pensionsalter
erreichen und hier muss gehandelt werden
da ein leistungsfähiger öffentlicher
dienst genau wie der bundeswehr ein
grundpfeiler unseres staates
konstituiert um neues personal zu
gewinnen und qualifiziertes personal zu
halten wurden in der vergangenheit viele
maßnahmen zur steigerung der
attraktivität der bundeswehr als
arbeitgeber in die tat umgesetzt die
arbeitsbedingung wurden verbessert die
besoldung angepasst und die soziale
absicherung der angestellten ausgeweitet
dadurch hat sie enorm an attraktivität
zu gewonnen natürlich wollen wir auch
das kostenlose bahnfahren in uniformen
nicht erwähnt lassen nicht unerwähnt
lassen und dennoch es gibt weiterhin
viel zu tun denn dienst in einer pendler
armee und die damit verbundenen
ständigen berufsbedingten ortswechsel
stellen eine enorme herausforderung für
die vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
dort wo es möglich ist muss das flexible
mobile arbeiten ausgeweitet werden auch
nach der pandemie und bei der
personalplanung verstärkt auf heimatnahe
verwendung gesagt werden wenn heimatnah
verwendung nicht ermöglicht sein kann
dann muss sichergestellt werden dass die
finanziellen mehraufwendungen
schnellstmöglich ausgeglichen werden
ebenfalls muss die ausstattung in den
kasernen und auch die infrastruktur der
bundeswehr modernisiert und verbessert
werden eine zeitgemäße ausstattung ist
unerlässlich die absicht auch hier das
tempo zu erhöhen ist gern gesehen
zusammenfassend die von der regierung
gesetzte marschrichtung ist in ordnung
dabei gilt es aber zu betonen dass diese
größtenteils lediglich die fortsetzung
eines bereits eingeschlagenen weges
darstellt
überrascht hat mich ihre aussage zu den
höheren finanzmitteln den maßnahmen zur
erreichung eben die also genannten
dieser eben genannten ziele die haben
ein preisschild und ohne die
hinterlegung der erforderlichen
finanzmittel verbleiben nur worthülsen
lippenbekenntnisse bringen uns und auch
die truppe und nicht voran angesichts
des gekürzten verteidigungshaushalte es
im finanzplan bis 2025 habe ich momentan
noch erhebliche bedenken dass es möglich
sein wird die soziale dimension der
verteidigungspolitik zu stärken und
zeitgleich die bundeswehr strukturell
und materiell vollumfänglich mit ihren
aufgaben wahrnehmen und wahrnehmungen zu
befähigen um somit unsere zusagen an
unsere verbündeten einzuhalten wir alle
nicht nur die regierungsparteien wollen
eine best möglich ausgestattete
bundeswehr wir als union sind aber davon
überzeugt dass bestmöglich ausgestattet
mit den zu erwarteten den finanzmitteln
nicht gut genug sein wird frau
ministerin das ist er in die junge
kollegen
überschritten zögern sie nicht uns nach
den vielen vielen guten ankündigungen
die wir heute gehört haben auch mit
taten zu überraschen die truppe hat es
verdient
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen noch mal
der hinweis
es sind ja schon immer mal ein paar
sekunden die wir dazu geben wenn wir das
gefühl haben sie kommen zum schluss aber
wenn sie dann immer wieder neu ansetzen
dann muss man sich einfach unterbrechen
also ich möchte gerne dass im
schlusssatz schön machen können aber
dann reagieren sie bitte auch auf dieses
signal als nächstes erhellten das wort
zu ihrer ersten rede im deutschen
bundestag die abgeordnete sarah
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe frau ministerin ja die
bundesregierung hat sich auch
sicherheitspolitisches
sicherheitspolitisch viel vorgenommen
und wissen sie worauf ich mich besonders
freue wir werden auslandseinsätze in
zukunft regelmäßig und ressort
übergreifend evaluieren
und sind wir mal ganz ehrlich das müsste
eigentlich selbstverständlich sein wenn
wir als deutscher bundestag die
soldatinnen und soldaten in den einsatz
schicken da müssen wir nicht nur vorher
genau wissen was der auftrag ist was die
ziele sind und wie die aussichten auf
erfolg aussehen sondern wir sollten auch
immer auch mit externer expertise frage
ob der auftrag den erfüllt wird welche
ziele nicht oder noch nicht erreicht
wurden und vor allem warum auch wenn es
weh tut
und das werden wir jetzt auch genau so
machen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das sind wir den soldatinnen schuldig
wir sind es aber auch den menschen in
den einsatzgebieten schuldig die
hoffnung in unserem einsatz in unser
engagement legen oder gelegt haben wie
unsere partner innen in afghanistan die
über 20 jahre an unserer seite
eingestanden sind für demokratie
rechtsstaat und menschenrechte die
internationalen truppen sind abgezogen
die taliban haben die macht übernommen
aber diese menschen streiten weiter vor
ort und im exil
rechtsstaatlichkeit demokratie und
menschenrechte
und auch die bundesregierung und das
parlament bleiben dran unsere
außenministerin hat den aktionsplan für
afghanistan ums leben gerufen eine ihrer
ersten einzahlung und die
innenministerin hat mit der aussicht auf
bessere bleibe möglichkeiten und teilen
habe ein klares zeichen gesetzt wir
vergessen euch nicht
und wir werden auch hier im parlament
mit einem untersuchungsausschuss die
evakuierungs mission des sommers
untersuchen es wird eine
enquete-kommission zum afghanistan
einsatz wo alle zu wort kommen müssen
die bundeswehr die beraterinnen aus dem
zivilen mission die entwicklungspartner
innen vor ort die zivilgesellschaft in
afghanistan und in deutschland und auch
hier ist die botschaft wir vergessen
euch nicht
und ja herr kollege das reicht nicht der
bundestag kann selbst nicht alle
aufarbeitung arbeit machen kleine
anregungen an alle die
zivilgesellschaftlich auch mit dem thema
befasst sind wir sind als parlament
ansprechbar wenn sie da auch in die
aufarbeitung gehen wollen ich glaube es
ist so gesamtgesellschaftlicher auftrag
liebe kollegen kollegin die bundeswehr
war im letzten und im vorletzten jahr
sehr sichtbar so sichtbar wie lange
nicht ja auch wegen der bilder aus kabul
aber auch wegen der bilder vom
hochwasser und aus den impfzentren
allen soldatinnen die sich deshalb die
ein oder andere extra und nachtschicht
um die ohren gehauen haben herzlichen
dank
sie haben wichtige arbeit geleistet und
leisten sie weiter aber für uns als
parlament muss auch klar sein wenn schon
heute naturkatastrophen zu nehmen wo es
in erster linie die zivil der zivilen
katastrophenschutz gestärkt werden denn
kernaufgabe der bundeswehr bleibt die
äußere sicherheit
kernaufgabe der bundeswehr ist also die
äußere sicherheit und dazu gehört dass
aufgaben und fähigkeiten zusammen passen
das ist eine binse wobei ich dazu sagen
möchte dass man sowohl bei den aufgaben
als auch bei den fähigkeiten einsetzen
kann um besser zu lange zu kommen und
alle kleine anmerkungen sein wir erlaubt
frei ministerin die frage ob und wenn ja
in welchem umfang und für für welche
medien mehr geld ausgegeben wird das
entscheiden wie hier in guter
zusammenarbeit mit ihrem haus aber
trotzdem letztendlich mit der mehrheit
hier im parlament
und 1 will ich auch klar sagen die
bundeswehr selbst kann einen beitrag zur
äußeren sicherheit leisten es ist eine
binse dass sich konflikte mit
militärischen mitteln nicht lösen lassen
deswegen ist für uns als ampelkoalition
die europäische abstimmung so wichtig
sie haben es selbst erwähnt deswegen
arbeiten wir auch daran die kohärenz
zwischen den häusern zu verbessern und
wir werden auch in rüstungskontrolle und
zivile krisenprävention mehr investieren
was ich jetzt in den letzten wochen
durch den kontakt auch versucht habe zu
truppe erlebt habe ist dass die
angehörigen der bundeswehr oft am besten
wissen oder eine zivile und politische
gesamtstrategie nutzt auch ein guter
fähigkeitslücken schließungsplan
herzlich wenig
ohne eine kohärente strategie ist alles
nicht liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
lade sie alle herzlich ein bringen sie
sich konstruktiv in die debatte um eine
kohärente außen und sicherheitspolitik
ein es gibt dort viel zu gewinnen
dankeschön
vielen dank
als nächste rednerin in dieser debatte
erhält das wort für die fdp-fraktion die
kollegin dr marie agnes strack
zimmermann
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
deutschland liegt im herzen europas und
ist wie johannes rau es anlässlich des
60-jährigen jahrestages nach kriegsende
gesagt hat von freunden umzingelt und
damit seine persönliche lehren aus dem 8
mai zog eine aussage welche die meisten
menschen als beruhigend empfand so
beruhigt und beglückt davon dass sie
nicht mit aggressiven grenz nachbarn zu
rechnen hatten so wurde frieden und
sicherheit zu einer puren
selbstverständlichkeit gesprochen wurde
in deutschland über die militärische
bundeswehr in der öffentlichkeit so gut
wie gar nicht wir sprechen jetzt
angesichts des tollen einsatzes bei
krone aber eben nicht über das
militärische das originäre für was die
bundeswehr da ist im gegenteil 16 jahre
oberbefehl kommandogewalt der cdu die
bundeswehr wurde runter gespart
standorte verschwanden personal mit viel
know-how frühzeitig in den ruhestand
geschickt und lieber kollege hahn das
ist jetzt nicht persönlich aber
lieber kollege nicht persönlich wer so
viel mist hinterlässt muss ich nicht
hier drauf setzen und auch noch laut
krenn meine damen und herren
das jahr 2014 lehrt uns dass seitens
russland grenzen wieder in frage
gestellt werden nachbarn annektiert und
brutalst angegriffen worden und deswegen
auch von hier aus und ich bin froh dass
die ministerin das so deutlich
angesprochen hat herr putin heute und
jetzt die europäische
sicherheitsstruktur ist nicht
verhandelbar und jedes land entscheidet
selbst welche kooperation es sucht und
es wird deswegen meine damen und herren
zeit über äußere sicherheit im deutschen
bundestag regelmäßig und grundsätzlich
zu debattieren auch um den menschen in
deutschland offen ehrlich ungeschminkt
direkt klar zu machen warum es im
wahrsten sinne des wortes und sehr viel
wert sein muss eine starke bundeswehr zu
haben und das schlägt sich auch unter
anderem im etat nieder die aussage des
verstorbenen spd verteidigungsminister
peter struck war unmissverständlich
und sie war richtig unsere sicherheit
wird nicht nur aber auch in anderen
ländern verteidigt und wer den
internationalen terrorismus nicht
bekämpft meine damen und herren der wird
nicht nur die vielen millionen menschen
in ihrer heimat ihre heimat nehmen
sondern er wird auch erleben dass der
terror vor unserer haustür aufschlägt
und an die linke gerichtet
schauen sie hin was dort mit frauen
passiert sie spitzen immer den mund und
band gepfiffen wird ziehen sie sich
zurück schauen sie sich das an daran
werden sie lieber kollege gemessen
werden sie besonders
und zu glauben dass es sicherheit zum
nulltarif gibt beide damen und herren
der verkennt die realität und schließt
die augen davor dass wir immer wehrhaft
sein müssen das müssen die anderen auch
wissen und dazu bedarf es einer
einsatzbereiten bundeswehr und ja die
gesellschaftliche wertschätzung für
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten die für
unsere freiheit ihr leben am langen ende
der einsetzen und es ist eben keine
wertschätzung wenn man nicht das beste
technische know-how geschafft meine
bundes meine damen und herren die
bundeswehr wird uns alleine aber nicht
schützen können sie kann in
krisengebieten einen moment für ruhe
sorgen am ende aber bedarf es der
diplomat und der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit um frieden zu
ermöglichen und deswegen gehört auch
dazu eine analyse der gründe weswegen
konflikte entstehen und dem werden wir
gerecht werden und meine damen und
herren deswegen brauchen wir eine enge
vernetzte zusammenarbeit auch und
besonders zwischen den ministerien und
frau ministerin lamprecht ich danke
ihnen auch für die einbindung des
parlamentes kollege hellmich hatte es
gerade gesagt und ich bitte auch die
ministerinnen frau baerbock und frau
schulze es ist zeit dass wir gemeinsam
zusammen diesen weg gehen ich danke
ihnen ganz
herzlichen dank frau kollegin
[Applaus]
nunmehr hat das wort für die
spd-fraktion zu seiner ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag kevin leise
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger unsere
fortschritts regierung macht auch in der
verteidigungs- und sicherheitspolitik
ihren namen alle ehre wir schaffen
fortschritt für die demokratie
fortschritt für die europäische
gemeinschaft und fortschritt für die
deutsche sicherheit
auf internationaler ebene bekennen wir
uns zu unseren bündnispartnern wir
wollen es sowohl in der nato als auch in
der eu weiterhin als verlässlicher und
ernstzunehmender partner agieren
ministerin lang recht hat dazu bereits
dies bereits eindrücklich geschildert da
mein kollege wolfgang heimlich hellmich
bereits auf die nato eingegangen es wird
ich mich auf die eu fokussieren
die regierungskoalition handelt im
europäischen selbstverständnis
eingebettet in das historische friedens
und freiheitsrechte europäischen union
denn die umbrüche des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts lassen sich nicht allein
national bewältigen auch wenn die afg
das noch immer nicht begreifen will
als eu werden wir uns künftig als
entschlossener entschlossener als
starker und eigenständiger akteur im
systemkonflikt zwischen freiheitlichen
demokratien und
totalitären regimen positionieren uns
vereint die prinzipien des völkerrechts
der menschenrechte unter europäischen
friedensordnung sie sind uns auftrag
orientierung und gemeinsame wertebasis
so schaffen wir fortschritt für die
demokratie
immer halt innerhalb der eu liegt die
herausforderung darin unterschiedliche
interessen zu einer gemeinsamen position
zusammen zu bringen wir können als
europäische staatengemeinschaft nur dann
ein garant von sicherheit sein wenn wir
auf kohärenz agieren wir werden die
arbeiten am strategischen kompass
konstruktiv mitgestalten in einer
europäische sicherheitsstruktur ist es
zu begrüßen dass wir als eu gemeinsame
handlungsleitlinien formulieren so
schaffen wir fortschritt für die
europäische gemeinschaft
die bundeswehr ist eine parlamentsarmee
sie besteht aus menschen für deren
bedürfnisse
arbeitsbedingungen und sicherheit wir im
deutschen bundestag die verantwortung
tragen die sicherheit in deutschland von
einer gut aufgestellten bundeswehr ab im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir vereinbart
was dabei zu tun ist die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr muss auf den prüfstand
gestellt und modernisiert werden
gleichzeitig werden wir die
attraktivität der bundeswehr als
arbeitgeberin verbessern auch dies hat
ministerin lamprecht bereits geschildert
die anzahl von cyber angriffen gegen
deutschland und unsere verbündeten in
nato und eu steigt dem treten wir mit
einer ehrgeizigen cyber
sicherheitspolitik entgegen der schutz
vor cyber-angriffen ist elementarer
bestandteil der sicherheit unserer
gesellschaft
ich bin im deutschen bundestag und neu
im verteidigungsausschuss in den
bisherigen gremiensitzungen und
gesprächsrunden ist mir die hohe
einsatzbereitschaft die leistungsstärke
und motivation der angehörigen unserer
bundeswehr positiv aufgefallen dieser
eindruck gibt mir zusätzlichen antrieb
unserer politischen verantwortung
gegenüber den streitkräften gerecht zu
werden die angehörigen der bundeswehr
riskieren ihre sicherheit für die
unseres landes
es liegt in unserer verantwortung alles
dafür zu tun damit die armee ihre arbeit
sicher effektiv und effizient nachkommen
kann mit einer verbesserten ausstattung
der bundeswehr einer ehrgeizigen cyber
sicherheitspolitik und einer
vertrauensvollen austausch mit den
angehörigen der bundeswehr schaffen wir
fortschritt für die sicherheit in
deutschland
die ausführung der union waren leider
geprägt von selbstgerechtigkeit und
vergesslichkeit die 4,9 prozent partei
die linke tut sich immer noch schwer
adäquat mit den realitäten der
internationalen ebene umzugehen im
gegensatz dazu schafft die fortschritts
regierung fortschritt für die demokratie
fortschritt für die europäische
gemeinschaft und fortschritt für die
sicherheit in deutschland
ich freue mich auf die umsetzung dieser
ziele zusammen mit allen staatstragenden
fraktionen dieses hauses und unsere
ministerin christine lambrecht für eine
starke bundeswehr statt die strategische
souveränität europas sowie eine enge und
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit mit
unseren bündnispartnern auch noch vielen
dank an meine verteidigern der spd
fraktion ihr seid klasse
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege leider
[Applaus]
und als letzter für diesen themenbereich
das wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion der
kollege jens lehmann
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin
gratuliere ihnen zu ihrem neuen amt und
wünsche ihnen alles gute und viel erfolg
für die anstehende arbeit
zunächst einmal möchte ich jedoch den
bundeswehr-soldaten für ihren dienst an
unserem land danken ich danke einen
soldaten auch für die großartige
unterstützung bei der bewältigung der
korona pandemie und nach der
flutkatastrophe im vergangenen sommer
ohne die engagierte arbeit der soldaten
wäre sicher so manches gesundheitsamt
zusammengebrochen und wurde das beherzte
anpacken dass er daten hätte die
schnelle beseitigung der ersten flut
schäden vermutlich wesentlich länger
gedauert
ich möchte den soldaten aber auch für
ihre gelassenheit banken anders kann man
wolle solche prioritätensetzungen wie zb
die umbenennung der ein mann packung in
einen personen packung nicht einordnen
angesichts der
verteidigungspolitischen themen die vor
uns liegen sollten wir es sollte aber
auch die bundeswehr den fokus auf
trinken
denn das gerät beispielsweise angesichts
der anhaltenden spannungen mit russland
und der situation entlang der
ukrainischen grenze die bundeswehr zu
ertüchtigen ihre kernaufgaben der
landes- und bündnisverteidigung recht zu
werden dazu brauche es eine gute
finanzielle ausstattung
wer hatte frau ministerin
dank ihrer beiden vorgängerinnen
verzeichnete einzelplan 14 seit jahren
eine steigende finanz linie beide
mussten allerdings hat mit dem damaligen
finanzminister olaf scholz verhandeln
schauen wir uns aber den von olaf scholz
bis 2025 geplanten eckwertebeschluss
ansehen wie ramos als die frau
ministerin langfristig eine fallende
finanz linie es im wahlkampf von urlaub
scholz überstrapaziert wird respekt
finde ich mit blick auf die bundeswehr
aber nicht wieder frau ministerin die
truppe ist nicht nur für die truppe
sieht der neue name eines ausrüstungs
artikel entscheidend sondern dass die
ausrüstung vorhanden ist und sie
funktioniert deshalb mein appell
stellen sie zu ihrem wort von eben
sorgen sie dafür dass die bundeswehr mit
ausreichenden mitteln versorgt wird um
dringend benötigte ausrüstung zu
beschaffen
wir wollten beispielsweise die
beschaffung von drohen schon in den
vergangenen legislaturperioden
aber die spd als koalitionspartner in
der regierungsverantwortung
verweigerte unseren soldaten in den
letzten acht jahren den schutz durch
dieses system
entschuldigen sie meine skepsis aber
angesichts des jüngst publik gewordenen
videos ihres ministerkollegen lindner
zur situation von ungeimpften fällt es
mir jetzt schon schwer an die einhaltung
von wahlkampfversprechen oder
koalitionsvereinbarungen daran glauben
deshalb
deshalb fordere ich sie auf
deshalb fordern wir als union
fraktionschef sorgen sie dafür dass die
bundeswehr bewaffnete drohnen erhält
sorgen sie dafür dass die bundeswehr
einen neuen schweren
transporthubschrauber erhält um nur zwei
beispiele zu nennen kurz gesagt sorgen
sie dafür dass die truppe alles an
material und ausstattung erhält was sie
zur auftragserfüllung
meine damen und herren
der truppe werden kurse aufgaben
übertragen und dazu wurde jetzt vieles
gesagt von vielen rednern woran ich ein
sprecher des beirats spitzensport der
bundeswehr aber auch gerne erinnern
möchte die bundeswehr ist der größte
sportförderer in deutschland die
gezielte sportförderung die defizite
forderung von sportlern wird die
bundeswehr ist einzigartig regelmäßig
holen die sportsoldaten die hälfte aller
olympischen medaillen nach hause auch
dank der unionsfraktion sind
mittlerweile 850 stellen in 15
sportfördergruppen mit schweizer daten
besetzt von denen viele in drei wochen
bei den olympischen winterspielen in
peking einen start gehen werden drücken
wir ihnen also die daumen für diese
anspruchsvolle sportliche mission
ein sie werte frau ministerin appelliere
ich erneut stärken sie auch unseren
sportlern den rücken setzten sie sich
weiterhin für eine starke
spitzensportförderung der bundeswehr ein
sehr geehrte damen und herren vor uns
liegen große herausforderungen wir
müssen die bundeswehr tüchtigen ihren
kernauftrag zu erfüllen wir müssen
antworten auf die situation in der
ukraine finden und wir müssen die
aufarbeitung des afghanistan einsatz
weiter vorantreiben denn kaum einen
einsatz hat vom ersten bis zum letzten
tag in deutschland politisch militärisch
und gesellschaftlich so viel verändert
das sind wir der gesellschaft
es sind wir vor allen dingen den
soldaten und ihren angehörigen schuldig
es liegt nun an ihnen in der
verantwortung in der neuen
bundesregierung dies umzusetzen
wir als unionsfraktion möchten unseren
teil dazu beitragen deshalb nehmen wir
ihre aussagen aus dem koalitionsvertrag
genau ins visier und werden sie daran
messen danke
vielen dank herr kollege lehmann
weitere wortmeldungen zu diesem
themenbereich liegen mir nicht vor